Speaker 1: So Colin Powell died of COVID complications,
severely immunocompromised, multiple myeloma,
Parkinson's and vaccinated eighty four years
old.
That's what we know Fox News and others doing
their sort of soft, anti-vax type stuff.
But Tucker Carlson really going fully, fully
in on it.
As Media Matters reports, Tucker Carlson claims
Colin Powells death proves quote you've been
lied to about vaccine effectiveness.
You've been lied to now, of course.
A vaccinated death in an 84 year old immunocompromised
individual doesn't disprove anything about
vaccines, doesn't say, doesn't indicate anybody
has lied.
People lie all the time about all sorts of
things.
Colin Powell dying is not proof.
Colin Powell dying is not proof that anybody
in particular is lying.
So let's take a look at this video clip.
Here is Tucker Carlson.
Let's just get right into it because we have
to start there to understand what the point
is that's being made here.
Speaker 2: A lot has changed in the years
since, and that's one of the reasons that
Colin Powell is deaf tonight is so poignant.
Like almost everyone his age, Colin Powell
was fully vaccinated against COVID.
And yet, according to his family and doctors,
Colin Powell died of COVID.
Of course, that fact does not make his death
any less sad.
Nor is it unusual.
Many thousands of vaccinated Americans have
died of COVID.
Former CDC director Robert.
Speaker 1: So first of all, understand when
we talk about the data thousands of Americans
dying of COVID out of 700 plus thousand deaths
and overwhelmingly the deaths are the unvaccinated
you.
If you don't understand that data, Tucker's
comment is extraordinarily confusing and a
lot of the people you know Tucker does that
confused face during his show.
Many of his audience members have that same
face.
They're just as confused
Speaker 2: and feels announced just today
that about 40 percent of all recent COVID
deaths in the state of Maryland, for example,
are among those who have had both
Speaker 1: shots.
Now, that's another deceptive thing.
Imagine a 100 percent vaccinated country in
a 100 percent vaccinated country, 100 percent
of deaths would be among vaccinated people.
Why is Maryland important?
Maryland is highly, highly vaccinated, so
you have to understand that's a mathematical
reality as well.
And there's a specific reason why Tucker talks
about Maryland.
Speaker 2: So what does that tell you exactly?
What tells you you've been lied to?
Vaccines may be highly useful for some people,
but across the population they do not solve
COVID.
Speaker 1: Now that's two different things.
The first of all, you've been lied to.
Well, what's the lie that you've been told?
Number two, vaccines are useful at every population
at reducing risk of death.
You might have one population with a higher
risk and one population with a lower risk
at all populations.
You have a lower risk of death when vaccinated.
Speaker 2: That's not speculation.
It is an observable fact that's not true.
Who've been fully vaccinated can still get
the virus through, can still transmit the
virus to others through, and they can still
die from COVID
Speaker 1: at dramatically lower rates
Speaker 2: when Powell is hardly the only
example of that.
So the question is why are they telling us
otherwise?
And the answer is simple.
They're telling us that to divide us from
brother,
Speaker 1: that is completely untrue.
I mean, this this is you have to understand
the motive here for Tucker, who's almost certainly
fully vaccinated, et cetera.
And, by the way, works for Fox News, which
has one of the strictest vaccine mandates
we've heard about for any large corporation.
The whole point here is get people afraid,
get people angry, afraid and angry.
And at the end of the broadcast, Tucker Carlson
casually mentions, Oh OK, I didn't mention
that Colin Powell was suffering from a number
of health problems.
Almost like an aside, he talked about being
Powell being fully vaccinated didn't mention
the health conditions.
Just kind of drops it in at the very end of
the show.
Speaker 2: Yeah, apparently, Dr. Doctor, thanks
so much for coming on.
I appreciate St. Luke's Hospital and my pleasure.
Appreciate it.
So the show we told you about Colin Powell,
we left out that Colin Powell was suffering
from a number of different health problems.
But of course, that's the point.
The point of vaccinating the vulnerable is
so people with other underlying health problems
won't die of COVID.
But unfortunately, it didn't work.
In the case of General Powell, it didn't work
for many thousands of other Americans.
And of course, that's the point we're making
in the first place.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
And what's funny is he's acting like this
is an important point that nobody else is
making.
No one ever said the vaccines are 100 percent
effective.
And when you talk about population level statistics
and you see the death rate among the unvaccinated
versus the death rate among the vaccinated,
the one story of Colin Powell.
Although Tucker is making a lot out of it,
although Fox News and others are making a
lot out of it, is not actually instructive.
It anyway doesn't prove anybody lied.
It doesn't prove that vaccines don't work.
It doesn't prove any of it.
But Tucker's audience is primed to accept
this stuff hook, line and sinker.
We'll talk a little more about the data later
in the show.
You can send me your thoughts.
Find me on Twitter at Packman.
Today is the David Pakman Show Live Viewer
Town Hall.
It'll be at 6:00 p.m. Eastern Time today,
Tuesday, October 19th.
It will be streaming.
On our Pacman Live YouTube channel, that's
not the main YouTube channel.
It's the second YouTube channel, Pacman Live.
We'll see you at 6:00 p.m. and we'll be back
in just a minute here